It's interesting to look at these things from obviously from multiple
perspectives,
which is another thing you had your logs don't do.
Right.
Because for them everything is one cause there's one,
that's how you can tell when you're dealing with someone who's ideologically
possessed is they make everything attributable to a single cause like power.
So,
but so one of the things that's happened with the nuclear family that's quite
interesting too is that parents are older and they,
and they have fewer children.
So you could imagine that that hot house environment in some senses being
exaggerated for a bunch of reasons.
One is,
well your child is a lot more valuable to you if you're older and you only have
one or two,
right?
Because you're not going to get another chance.
That's first of all,
you might've had some trouble having the child to begin with.
Um,
and you're not going to get another chance.
So you've got all your eggs are in one basket,
so to speak.
And then of course children don't have the number of siblings they used to have.
And one of the things that's really useful about having siblings is that they
keep you in your place,
right?
They,
they're primary socialization agents.
And I mean that can be brutal.
And that's reflected say in the story of Cain and Abel.
You know,
that that internal household dynamic with siblings can be,
can really become murderous and that has to be kept under control.
But I think the,
the,
the hothouse flower person who's,
who's incapable of tolerating any jibes or any or any testing,
any dominance hierarchy testing of the sort that you said that men do,
part of that's the consequence of being raised by older parents who have excess
resources,
who have no siblings because the child is then of course special and that
specialness,
well there,
there seems to be an inverse relationship between that specialness that's
protected and the person's robustness and resilience.
And so,
and then that's cotton to,
or not cotton too.
That's,
that's uh,
uh,
pandered to by the universities,
which insist upon setting up a situation where no one has ever offended by
anything,
any of the time.
That's something I also can't understand at all.
Right.
Cause it,
let me just say that's a huge point you just made.
Okay.
Because it's the upper middle class of the purpose of the Fred professional
class who postpones having the children.
Okay.
Because they go to law school,
they go to medical school.
Right.
And they,
and they have the children after their,
their,
their settled.
Okay.
In,
in,
in a drop.
Okay.
So they're the ones.
W we have it injected this,
this,
this hypersensitive bourgeois.
I didn't,
you know,
code into the universities.
Now My,
my parents were 20 when they married in 21 when they had me.
Okay.
It made,
my father was,
um,
you know,
uh,
went to college on the Gi Bill,
getting out of,
out of World War II.
So w w when I was born,
my father was still in college and with the sweeping the floors and so on,
I am the product of young parents and nature once actually Yucca parents.
Right.
Because,
because pregnancy is,
is,
is quicker,
it's safer.
Okay.
And so on.
And my parents had the energy.
Okay.
Too.
That's useful energy that can do spirit that came out of world war two and so
on.
I'm positive that then.
Then my only other sibling was born 14 years later.
Okay.
My father,
this point was a college professor.
Right.
All right.
So she had completely different parents then and then I did.
So she has very excellent manners and so on.
She's completely different.
Okay.
All right.
And I have all this energy of,
I mean it might,
my parents were just a lot of other teams,
but now today we have this situation.
No,
it's considered heresy to raise this issue.
Okay.
That you have have young women are told,
okay,
there's one future for you.
You are a future leader.
Okay.
You must,
you must move forward four years of college and,
and,
and perhaps it was a professional class.
All right,
so it may be the women,
young women's bodies are signaling that they want to be [inaudible].
Maybe,
maybe there are signals coming from the body,
right?
Maybe now wanting this,
this,
this system of education that was devised for men.
Okay.
This is being funneled along channel long and it's next.
Awesome.
All right.
So young women,
you know,
a few unhappy,
they don't know why they feel,
they have no sense of identity.
If they,
if they,
if they want to marry and drop out of college and have,
have a baby,
they will be treated as traitors to their class.
What you are future leader?
What have a baby only working class women would do that I find working class
women.
Okay.
In general.
Far more rounded as personalities.
They express themselves forcefully.
They have body language that takes up space.
Okay.
A man says something to them on the street there,
right back in their face and so on.
It does the bourgeois girls.
Okay.
Who are talking to them at their core.
They are a special,
okay,
we'll have to postpone actual life.
Okay.
For him for all these years,
these cds,
these other girls who are,
who are,
who misjudged the fraternity parties setting.
These are the girls who like rotten for parental protection and handholding on,
on the,
on the committee investigating what went wrong on our date and so on and so
forth.
So yes,
I think that you have located,
that's very interesting.
The idea that the,
that these,
these young girls,
okay.
Who are so sensitive.
Okay.
In College,
so I'm able to handle their sex life are the product of older parents because
they went through the professional career track.